نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن مسئولينا
امرتينا قولهم ان مهاجمي خط نورت ستريم
العام الماضي كانوا على الارجح من
اوكرانيا او روسيا او من البلدين معا ولم
يشارك في العمليه اي امريكي او بريطاني
وكشفت الصحيفه الراجعت معلومات
استخباراتيه جديده تشير الى ان مجموعه
مواليه لاوكرانيا نفذت الهجوم على خطوط
الانابيب ونقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤولين قولهم
انه ليس لديهم اي دليل على تورط الرئيس
الاوكراني او كبار مساعديه في العمليه او
ان الجناه كانوا يتصرفون بتوجيه من اي
مسؤول حكومي اوكراني
من جانبها افادت صحيفه الالمانيه بان
المحققين الالمان تمكنوا من تحديد السفينه
التي استخدمت في تفجير انابيب الغاز نورد
ستريم في بحر البلطيط مضيفه النواطنين
اوكرانيين قد يكونوا وراء العمليه وقالت
الصحيفه ان تحقيقا مشتركا اجرته مع شبكه
اي ار دي الاعلاميه وصحيفه اس دبليو ار
يدل على اثر اوكراني في عمليه تفجير الخط
على الرغم من انه لا يزال مجهولا من امر
بتنفيذه وبحسب معلومه الصحيفه فان
المحققين كشفوا ان السفينه التي استخدمت
لتنفيذ العمليه هي يخت تم استئجاره من
شركه بولنديه يعتقد انها مملوكه من قبل
اوكرانيين